to me when people say to me sometimes  like boy you know you go after the left  a lot these days why I'm like because  you're embarrassing me  that's why I'm going after the left but  I think we should have one national  anthem I think when you go down a road  where you're having two different  national anthems  colleges sometimes now have many of them  have different graduation ceremonies for  black and white  separate dorms this is what I mean  segregation  you've inverted the idea  we're going back to that everything that  Bill said there is now conservative yes  we shouldn't have two national anthems I  don't know what he meant by we should  maybe change our national anthem no we  shouldn't  um but yes they're teaching racism in  school they're teaching this hyper  racialized thing in school it's coming  there's no liberals to stand up for this  stuff